mais jeudi à tout faire et ce que mes
jeudis l'avatar dont il est chargé
d'assistance en assurance et vous avez
une relation avec une femme de 53 ans
vous en aviez 18 et vous avez été
dégoûté alors bas vous jeter pour
lausanne
bah ouais bah un petit peu non il faut
dire que je vais être honnête
ouais vous êtes contraint howe a
clairement ouais donc alors en sortir
avec ma grand mère je pas le timbre
d'accord non mais elles n ont plus leur
arrive pas elle non plus à la
déconfiture à faire donc c'est vrai mais
je demande son avis sur toile avec des
personnels ou c'est d'abord d'abattage
général d'abord non mais déjà il n'aime
pas généralement à bord il a son atelier
et son expérience personnelle a fait que
c'est une mauvaise expérience or
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé vous êtes
sorti avec une 22 53 ans c'était ça
s'est passé comment et ben en fait je
vais rencontrer
normalement tu vois tout çà bendor oui
en extérieur donc un au monde extérieur
et je vais prouver mais j'avais se
trouvait j'avais écouté enfin trouvé ce
côté maternel donc je la prenais un peu
comme une 2e marié 18 ans voilà je la
prenais un peu comme une deuxième maman
est en fait au final je me suis aperçue
qu'elle avait quelques rapprochements
qui était vicieux j'appellerais ça c'est
à dire elle commence à me caresser un
peu là puis c'est tout ça non mais vous
vous avez une aventure avec elle non
même pas non après à parler d'accord ça
commence à et ça a commencé comme ça et
après donc je suis parti chez elle je
pars tu manges et tout ça on s'est posé
sur le canapé ouais et là bas c'est
parti quoi
[Rires]
la forme pour votre merci tout
maigrichons comme vous êtes vous n'avez
pas pu vous défendre elle avait beaucoup
de griche l'anaré vous ne vous étiez
vous étiez consentants donc non je les
entends voilà aux actions auxquelles
vous a plu sur le nom quoi vous a été
attaqué les enlever ses vêtements quoi
ça pendouiller un peu trop arrêté lé va
peser 50 3 ans m'a dit non mais quand à
laver ses vêtements c'est vrai qu'elle
était belle on est même un embêtement
non non non elle laissait pas bien
conservée pour son arrêt quoi et donc et
vous avez combien de temps avec elle un
d'apprécier combien de temps avec elle
ça va durer trois semaines
au bout de trois semaines j'ai couché
avec elle quoi au bout de trois semaines
et une fois que vous avez couché
lesquels vous l'avait plus revu alors
terminé non quoi ça vous avez non j'ai
même que j'ai même pas couché pendant
six mois après ah oui
vous imaginez pas si vous ne la prend la
pole pendant 12 ans arrêté jeudi au
respect moi j'aime pas ça ce en quoi
vous dire moi je vais vous dire que mes
50 ans dans la lah vous êtes dur quand
même
non je suis rien vous étiez dur aussi
avant mais là non non franchement non
mais vous avez dit quoi vous avez vous
avez été gentleman avec elle quand même
vous l'avez dit on vous l'avait dit quoi
non je lui envoie un petit et ça mais je
dis que ça ne ferait pas la faim dans
ben si il faut bien lui dire elle me
vous était alors vous alors je vous y
avez bien là vous me décevez pourquoi ça
se fait pas en un sms à se fait pas bell
a pris direct un moment donné quand elle
a vu que ça montait plus elle a compris
alors à côté vous là stéphane edouard
qui est affligé non mes fans cette
sociologue vous avez écrit deux livres
50 leçons pour séduire et êtes-vous
faits l'un pour l'autre
vous pensez comme au quotidien ou hétéro
binaire de base est forcément berné par
le polyamour parce qu'il croit être un
accès à une sexualité libre déjà et sur
la différence d'âge vous dites quoi
alors sur la différence d'âge alors déjà
le premier truc mais on a remarqué le
même mais on s'est arrêté sur le mot
consentement ouais mon voisin de droite
aurait été une femme et un homme de 55
ans lui aurait passé la main sur la
cuisse vous auriez le csa au cul chers
amis c'est vraiment et là ça fait rire
tout le monde
non mais il a raison c'est vrai il a dit
aussi avait franchement stéphane on va
demander aux membres du csa
oui elle l'a quitté
alors alors oui merci c'est gentil par
rapport à la différence d'âge proprement
dit s'il veut faire de la sociologie
sérieuse dans les quelques secondes que
je vais avoir découpé
il est temps pour moi il faut faire la
différence entre ce qu'ils fassent une
fois et celui récurrent en fait dire que
quand on a une expérience une fois et
qu'elle est désagréable c'est un petit
peu comme si sur un calendrier de
l'avent en tire un chocolat en disant
bon ce jour-là il est fini on passe à
autre chose
ça m'a permis par le en en étant un peu
écoeuré de quelque chose passer à autre
chose quand quelque chose est récurrent
en par contre quand au contraire quand
c'est récurrent quand ça se reproduit
souvent c'est en général qu'en fait on
n'est pas arrivé à à passer à la suite
donc il ya un très bon il ya un roman
mythique là dessus qu'ils s'appellent
lolita wydadis eric naulleau laluque
beaucoup beaucoup cité que finalement
peu qu'on lui où le héros explique un
petit peu mieux qu'il ya deux mois que
cela fait deux mois dernier mais c'est
la même chose il ya qu'en fait ce sont
ils focalisent sur des femmes plus
jeunes parce qu'elle leur échapper à
l'âge où il aurait dû et les avoir donc
en réalité c'est l'aveu d'un échec
c'est je fais plus tard avec mon argent
ce que j'aurais dû faire avant avec un
à-côté mon talent c'est ça